So what can we do with
a sensor like this?
Let's first talk about depth estimation.
Using this sensor and
this kind of a coded aperture, they
were able to compute depth in one single
image just using this coded aperture.
This is the output they would get.
Not perfect, but this is what
you get out of a single image.
And then they actually came up with
an algorithm that would regularize
the depth to able to
generate an image like this.
I encourage you to look at the concept
of regularization, but among other
things, it basically is one of the best
ways of smoothing out the information.
And that basically is the way that
this kind of detail were kind of
gotten rid of.
And allow you to kind of generate
a much better mask for depth.
So of course, if you look at
it after doing regularization
you can actually get a much
better sense of depth.
In this paper they also kind of
suggest that the sometimes,
by simple manual intervention,
you can also improve results.
Another example of this kind of stuff,
again where you have
regularized depth here.
Some of the stuff is lost, but
again, from a simple camera,
you can actually do quite well
with these types of things.
And here, by just adding a little
bit of corrections manually you can
actually now get the shapes that you
wanted, or the depth that you wanted.
And these are the gestures that were
actually acquired to help you do this.
Let's look at a few exam,
other examples.
This is an example of focus corrections.
So, of course, this is an input and you
can see a lot of focusing, you know, and
defocusing artifacts here.
Of course it's not completely
all defocused here.
But, with this method, now we know
the things we can actually use this to
deconvolve the thing, and now the whole
image is completely in focus.
Another example to just look at this is,
this was the original image and
if you just zoom in,
in this output image.
And again, the coded image
captured all of the details,
allowing you to after the fact,
in a post-editing mode,
be able to now actually
visualize a focused image.
Another close-up is this example here,
when given an input image of two people.
One you can see is badly focused,
and of course,
now the whole image has
been focused correctly.
Again, the camera captured
all the information and
you can do this after the fact.
And, the example again is the original
image had a lot of focus blur, and
you can see a much sharper
image as the output.
Of course, we could do some sort
of you know, naive sharpening and
stuff like that and get simple
examples like this on this image and
again, there are methods out there.
But again, the point basically being
this was done on the camera itself
with the coded aperture.